I felt like terminator you know I mean I
felt like I could go forever another
thing is I was at the gym and I was able
to do about three times as many pull-ups
as I normally can Wow
I can't I couldn't laugh and I was that
was before I would ever learned about
you before I hadn't listened to any
talks on it I didn't know what ki
ketosis was this was last year in 2019
and I just literally I was explaining
this to people and I could not wrap my
brain around how I was able to to do so
many pull-ups and play basketball for so
long with zero fatigue yeah that just
kind of explains it yeah bodyweight
exercises - I didn't push myself to the
edge but I think I would jump up and do
like 20 Chin's like outside our house or
whatever like on a tree yeah and I
didn't want to push it but that those 20
reps which would like fairly strict
chin-ups felt pretty easy like if I go I
can do about 36 or 37 chops or something
like that Wow but the 20 just felt
really easy and you can make them a
little bit harder you can kind of like
stretch the lats at the bottom and then
contract at the top and towards the end
of it it was like trying to make the
chin-ups harder so do the 20 but like
super strict right and tracked and I
knew I didn't want to sort of stress out
the body too much because you know I was
worried that you know fasting but I
probably didn't need to worry but yeah
but yeah when I do a big lift
I don't fast seven days but I do like to
go into it relatively fast it and I feel
that if my body is not dealing with
digesting assimilating mechanically you
know to enzymatically it's not dealing
with a meal that I have more energy and
resources to activate muscle and I feel
my feeling intuitively is that my
central nervous system can activate the
muscle better it's it's almost like
those pathways neurological pathways are
activated when I'm in a semi fasted
state I think if I fast for more than
like 24 or 48 hours my energy reserves
are generally going to be a little bit
lower and that might be not it might not
be advantageous for a max lift but may
for like bodyweight exercise but when it
comes to doing a max lift I would never
go into it like a lot of guys eat right
before they get to the gym or whatever I
would typically fast probably at least
six to eight hours sometimes 10 or 12
hours before if I'm like really going
for a metal or a left yeah but I would
eat up the weeks the days before maybe
even start out 3 or 4 days before and
start eating like a lot of red meat and
so whenever I set a PR I kind of have
this whole sort of thing that I go
through where I eat up and I ramp up
like 25% more calories like kind of two
days out and I kind of really protein
everything and it's not super scientific
but I kind of I put you know portion
things out a little bit different that
I'm goin to a calorie surplus the day
before but that day of I go into the max
lift fasted okay like where some people
would think it's insane thrive to you
know 12 hours fasted but in my strength
is definitely more I my nervous system
is better at recruiting muscle I'm
pretty sure of that I know I need to do
the EMG used to show it but I think
would be an interesting study to do yeah
definitely do you I mean do you find
that in the scientific community people
look at you differently based on you
know if you look at your Instagram for
example I mean your deadlifting way
you're eating tons of meat I mean it
doesn't look like you're a scientist I
don't think I don't think like well if
you're if you're studying like sports
science you know I mean there's a lot of
meatheads I guess ya go to like a sports
science thing like bodybuilder
powerlifter kind of guys this is
something I've always done since the age
of like 1314 you know lifting weights my
brother was like a huge benchpress
monster you know I don't think I've ever
even caught up to him on that I mean and
he's not even he's never even drank a
protein shake before I mean he's just
intolerant fishing and just when he's
passed him by the bench he'll just put
four plates on it a weight of like 185
he's repping with like four or five so I
think the genetics were there really
though he doesn't train legs or
back even but he still we worked on a
farm together for a while he always was
just like that farm strength and just
like a crazy bench strength so that
really motivated me as a kid to sort of
try to be as strong as him but also when
I played football I got into it mm-hmm
so that's always been part of like Who I
am but I don't necessarily especially
now want to make it my persona to do
that but I want it I want people to know
for me strength training is really an
anti-aging therapy and I think for me
it's also like a psychological therapy I
don't know I took a year off of training
with weights but I was working heavy on
the farm doing a lot of labor and I take
the dogs for walk every night and jump
up and do a couple sets of chin ups and
push ups and dips so I was doing all
that kind of stuff but it took a year or
more completely away from weight so I
didn't even pick up a weight but when I
got back to it I realized you know there
is a difference between sort of like
lifting weights and just kind of playing
around on the farm and doing push-ups
and Chin's I mean that stuff I still do
that stuff but lifting like serious
weight or the bars bending and you're
it's almost like a life or death kind of
thing yeah whole the whole mentality of
approaching the lift is kind of what I
enjoy it's like I actually I envision a
scenario where it is life or death and I
kind of a calm person so I do think I do
some mental gymnastics to basically
create like a life-or-death scenario or
something that kind of gets me my
sympathetic nervous system activated
or I can do that and I miss sort of that
whole routine of doing that so now I'm
kind of embracing that been doing that
for the last couple months now back in
the gym I built my wife and I used to go
to the gym but then we just like didn't
have time so I was like okay I'm just
getting some weights I'm gonna put it in
the house and so I am enjoying the home
gym or barn gym a lot now and doing that
probably about three times a week so
that but I don't think I get really a
stigma or right sometimes people
criticize me online for you know do in
certain podcasts or
[Music]
you know doing research on a fad diet or
I try not to sensationalize the results
that we have and I talk within the realm
of the published science I think that's
important especially when you're doing
things research related to cancer
because I do get lots of emails from
Alzheimer's patients cancer patients and
patients with rare disorders and I do
not try to over promote or oversell the
diet in any way shape or form I try to
do the opposite actually
and there are a lot of people who are
advocates of the ketogenic diet that
just go too far and I try to be a voice
of reason that's somewhere in the middle
mm-hmm there's a lot of antagonistic
people who really maybe are out to get
me too and they just say the ketogenic
diet is dangerous it's not yeah why do
you think that is I think there's
different read I think maybe they
actually believe that but I'm coming at
it from the perspective that the diet
was a very powerful medical therapy for
epilepsy and that's really I study
seizures that's most of my funding comes
from studying seizures so I'm convinced
of that
I guess the pushback comes from the
ketogenic diet as a lifestyle and like I
said it might not be optimal for most
people is probably not the clinical KJ
but a modified form of a low-carb diet
is undoubtably I feel optimal getting
back to your question for humans in no
point in history did we have access to
the level of sugar processed
carbohydrates that we do now so it just
makes I mean it's like it just makes
obvious sense to not necessarily
eliminate these things but to minimize
them in our diet so right now they are
the predominant source of calories in
the diet so yeah they really are
it's crazy the federal government gives
out like food stamps or they give out
supplements to people to buy to buy food
and they're using those supplements for
sugary drinks and they're using it for
processed carbohydrates so this we need
to subsidize vegetable growers you know
fruits and vegetables predominant fruits
are
good part of that too but our government
is basically their programs are
supporting the purchase of heavily
subsidized commodities that are sort of
linked to the corn industry and soybean
and these are all things I grew growing
up fine yeah right so I'm kind of keenly
aware of it but policy needs to change
[Laughter]